three numbers until about ten or fifteen
minutes from now so I will not comment
on that
country though is doing very well in
every respect that they were just doing
we're knocking it out of the park
[Music]
I'm very happy about that we did not pay
money for fire great auto no money paid
big reward money was paid I haven't paid
money for any options that I've got
approximately I think it's 20 or 21 out
we don't pay money for hostages
I don't case is a very unusual case but
I just want to let you know no money
would say Otto
I never told Don began to fire Muller if
I wanted to fire Muller I would have
done it myself it's very simple I had
the right to and frankly whether I did
or he did we had the absolute right to
fire Muller in the meantime I didn't do
it I'm excluded of history I see what
you get when you fire people and it's
not good but there would have been
nothing wrong with firing and legally I
had absolute right to fire but I never
told Don began to fire color by the way
and Muller finished out his report no
collusion and no obstruction I think we
beat him easily
quick
they have to get the job the vaccination
is so important this is really going
around now they have to get their shot
[Music]
well I think that I just feel like a
young man I'm so young I can't believe
it I'm the youngest person I am a young
vibrant man I look at Joe I don't know
about him I don't know
I know the Royal making me look very
young both in terms of age and I think
in terms of energy I think you people
know that better than anybody
I've answered that question and if you
look at what I said you will see that
that question was answered perfectly and
I was talking about people that went
because they felt very strongly about
the monument to robert e lee a great
general whether you like it or not he
was one of the great generals I spoken
to many general here right at the White
House and many people thought of the
generals they think that he was maybe
their favorite general
people were there protesting the taking
down of the monument of robert e lee
everybody knows
[Music]
very well with North Korea not of
progress is being made
I appreciated president Putin's
statement yesterday he wants to
there's a lot of excitement we're
getting the deal done with North Korea
in the meantime when I came here the
world nuclear test missile test rocket
said we got our hostages back we got two
remains back and continued to come back
from the war that a great heroes do we
made there's no test this and no nothing
so at some point you're gonna report the
fact I have a great relationship with
Kim jong-un
I appreciate that right yet as China is
helping us and China is helping us
because I think they want to you know
these nuclear weapons right next to
their country but I also think they
helping us because with the fact that
weren't as radio which by the way is
going very well
[Music]
what we're doing is executive so what
we're doing the history of our country
there has never been a president that's
been more transparent than me or the
Trump administration
I let White House Counsel McGann testify
I let everybody festivai think again I
think again was in there for 30 hours
who ever heard of such a thing
but I said I want everybody to testify
obviously began Tony testified fine
because he would put the administration
for a long time after that and I think
he said he was just joining up with
respect to the appointment of judges by
the minute
but I let everybody testify there has
never ever been transparency like this
so God so just so you understand so we
got a great
we get the ruling which I knew we were
gonna get because I have nothing to do
with Russia and the campaign so we get a
ruling no collusion we essentially get a
ruling no obstruction based on the back
our great Attorney General made an
immediate decision there was no
obstruction so we have no collusion no
instruction we had total transparency we
gave 1.4 million documents if you can
believe such a ridiculous thing
500 people testified we had 18 people
that were true haters let it lose mr.
Mallory was a debater wait a minute wait
wait wait with all of this with all of
this with all of this transparency we
finished no collusion no obstruction
right then I get out to first say this
thing let's do it again and I said
that's enough
we got it we have to run a country we
have a very great country to run and
frankly when I go through it with the
house and
and we have no pollution no pollution no
obstructions no obstruction then we have
again we have to go through it this is a
fueled political witch-hunt we did
nothing wrong and the only thing I did
is make our country stronger given the
numbers like people haven't seen before
what we're doing in this country
potentially with the military with our
veterans you look at better as we now
have veterans joys nobody's ever done
what I've done in their first two years
so if I'm guilty of anything it's that
I've been a great president and the
Democrats don't like it the colleges
Indianapolis we're going to the NRA and
the poet
easily